war zone 2 might have a release date and
war zone 1 is getting accused of
plagiarism
release dates for call of duty war zone
2 and world of warcraft dragonflight
have allegedly been leaked the since
deleted image appears to show an
internal documentation related to
readiness for various upcoming
activision blizzard launches such as the
recently announced release date of the
pre-patch for world of warcraft wrath of
the lich king classic though random
images posted to reddit shouldn't be
accepted as fact there is at least some
evidence to back this particular one up
for example the aforementioned release
date for wrath of the lich king classics
pre-patch though blizzard has since
announced the official date this image
was on reddit several hours before
blizzard's announcement if the image is
indeed legitimate world of warcraft
players can expect to have their hands
on the game's new expansion dragonflight
on november 28th with the game's
pre-patch arriving roughly a month
earlier on october 25th meanwhile call
of duty war zone 2 could be launching
november 16th several weeks after the
release of call of duty modern warfare
2. in addition to war zone 2 the
document lists a release for october
27th for something called cod cortez
which may be the heavily rumored and
seemingly confirmed dmz mode it's best
to take this leak if that indeed is what
it is with a grain of salt in other call
of duty news activision has announced a
new pre-order bonus for call of duty
modern warfare 2 and it's a first of its
kind offer for the franchise everyone
who digitally pre-orders the game will
get access to its campaign mode up to a
week early starting on october 20th
pre-ordering modern warfare 2 also gets
you early access to the multiplayer beta
which begins september 16th on
playstation before coming to xbox and pc
later and now let's talk about a little
call of duty drama activision has
released the new doomsayer operator skin
in call of duty warzone and vanguard but
players are already pointing out major
similarities with artwork from dr
disrespect's upcoming dead drop game
dead drop is a vertical extraction
shooter currently in development from dr
disrespect and the midnight society
studio and the community was involved
early on with some people earning or
purchasing dead drop founders passes to
acquire one of ten thousand variants
which are unique in-game characters
randomly assigned to founders oddly
enough call of duty's doomsayer skin
features a design that looks much like
former infinity war developer robert
bowling's dead drop variant while it
could be a coincidence and completely
unrelated bowling has since made a vague
tweet that says quote at least name it
after me so what do you think big
coincidence or what also warzone this
year i was convinced it would be next
spring
also let me not get ahead of myself like
i said take it with a grain of salt we
don't know if it's 100 true that it's
dropping in november but if it does
like i'll gladly be wrong
but like i was so convinced
you